d'ailleurs en plein centre de la
capitale des manifestants lancent des
pierres sur les forces de l'ordre qui
ont barré une route permettant d'accéder
au parlement
c'est là que député ministre assiste à
une session consacrée au vote du budget
2020 un vote dont les manifestants ne
veulent pas certains cherchent même à
bloquer les voitures qui se dirige vers
le parlement
il pointe du doigt une classe dirigeante
qu'ils accusent de corruption et
d'incompétence inutile le droit de
briser notre mur humain pour atteindre
le parlement n'était-il pas plus facile
pour eux d'annuler cette cession
illégale consacrée au budget du
gouvernement qui n'a pas reçu de vote de
confiance a été proposé par un
gouvernement que nous avons forcé à
démissionner est il acceptable qui le
défendent
non les manifestants considèrent le vote
du budget 2020 comme une violation de la
constitution
mais la session a bien eu lieu le
gouvernement ne s'opposera pas un budget
qui a été préparé par le gouvernement
précédent et a été discuté par les
commissions parlementaires et celles des
affaires courantes et dont les
procédures étaient achevés par
conséquent le gouvernement laissera le
parlement décidé tout en se réservant le
droit de soumettre des lois pour amender
le budget après avoir gagné un vote de
confiance dans un pays au bord de
l'effondrement économique
ce vote était contestée au sein même des
partis politiques
résultat 70 députés sur 128 étaient
présents pour la séance
le projet de budget a été approuvé avec
une majorité relative de 49 députés
il prévoit un déficit de plus de 4,2
milliards de dollars soit environ 7% du
pib
[Musique]